[Musique]
alors là en fait on est super tôt le
matin en plein milieu de la saison
d'Annie et je viens juste d'arriver dans
une fête clandestine en plein milieu de
la campagne et de la forêt et c'est
assez impressionnant parce qu'il y a
vraiment tout type de personnes ici il y
a des laïcs et des religieux c'est assez
incroyable
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que c'est mais ça c'est les
feeling c'est on fait ça c'est truc de
jeu pour le statut non je suis pas vieux
ah ok
j'aime la nature j'aime la musique
j'aime les copains
la guerre on se on rentre pas trop
dedans nous on aime
le peace and love
alors juste pour vous donner un petit
peu de contexte il y a presque un an
maintenant j'avais réalisé un reportage
sur les musulmans Palestiniens de
Jérusalem lors du ramadan si vous ne
l'avez pas encore vu je vous invite
vraiment à aller le voir je vous mets le
lien en description mais cette fois-ci
j'ai eu envie d'aller voir l'autre côté
les Juifs israéliens alors vous le savez
toutes et tous le conflit
israélo-palestinien c'est un sujet
ultra
ultra complexe j'ai malheureusement pas
du tout le temps de le résumer ici dans
cette vidéo mais pour celles et ceux qui
veulent aller plus loin je vous mets
plein de liens en description bon
reprenons l'histoire depuis le début
pourquoi j'ai voulu faire ce sujet au
départ ça n'avait rien à voir avec
l'étoffeurs eux voulaient reverrez en
toute fin de reportage toute a commencé
quand en janvier sur Youtube je suis
tombé sur cette vidéo qui m'avait fait
un peu flipper
sur cette vidéo on y voit deux groupes
de personnes à gauche il y a des
randonneurs et à droite un groupe de
jeunes juifs israéliens s'approche d'eux
avec des battes de baseball
[Musique]
un accélération
parmi les victimes il y a des
randonneurs Palestiniens mais aussi des
Français des Américains et des Italiens
j'ai voulu comprendre qui était ces
jeunes en faisant quelques recherches
j'ai découvert qu'il faisait partie d'un
groupe qu'on appelle les jeunes des
collines
bon ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que quand
je vais tourner ce sujet en février le
contexte du pays est assez particulier
puisqu'une nouvelle coalition a remporté
les élections
c'est désormais le gouvernement le plus
à droite de l'histoire d'Israël qui est
aujourd'hui au pouvoir avec un ministre
de la Sécurité Nationale clairement
d'extrême droite
il soutient les colonies illégales dans
les territoires palestiniens et donc
indirectement les jeunes des collines
les jeunes colons que vous avez vu
agresser les randonneurs quand j'ai
proposé ce sujet à la rédaction de brute
en fait ça a pas mal fait débats est-ce
qu'on faisant un focus sur les colons
juifs radicaux en Israël on risquerait
pas de nourrir l'antisémitisme en France
on a donc choisi d'aller à la rencontre
des différentes jeunesses juives
israéliennes les jeunes des collines qui
sont ultra-nationalistes religieux et
procolonisation mais aussi des jeunes
activistes d'extrême gauche qui sont eux
contre la colonisation
et j'ai aussi eu envie de rencontrer
celles et ceux qui essayent de profiter
de leur jeunesse malgré le contexte et
c'est souvent la majorité silencieuse
[Musique]
quand j'ai commencé à enquêter j'ai
trouvé la page Facebook des jeunes des
collines et j'avoue que je m'attendais
pas du tout à cette ambiance
[Musique]
ont été condamnés à de lourdes peines
par la justice israélienne et notamment
pour homicide volontaire mais comme ils
invitent les médias à venir les voir
j'ai donc saisi l'opportunité
on vient de passer le portail et là du
coup on rentre dans une des nombreuses
zones inquiétude par les jeunes des
collines
[Musique]
toutes petites colonies illégales au
milieu des territoires palestiniens là
on vient juste d'arriver on vient de
rencontrer par chance un des leaders du
mouvement des jeunes des collines qui
s'appelle Alisha
gala
alors en fait comment ça fonctionne un
post avancé en général sont un peu des
pionniers les jeunes des collines sont
les premiers à arriver sur un territoire
palestinien il s'installe et construit
de toutes petites maisons ils ramènent
des troupeaux de moutons ils font de
l'agriculture pour prendre la place
prendre la palestinien d'année en année
en fait ces petits villages grossissent
jusqu'à devenir de petites villes et ça
va peut-être ce moment-là que très
souvent le gouvernement israélien rend
légal c'est colonies on en parle souvent
parler de violences commises par les
jeunes des collines envers des civils
palestiniens qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez vous
on est Sauveur
du coup vous avez choisi de vivre ici à
la campagne dans les conditions aussi
difficile
en fait en Israël le service militaire
est obligatoire pendant 2 à 3 ans pour
les femmes comme pour les hommes et à
partir de 18 ans mais les chats il n'a
jamais pu faire son service l'armée n'a
jamais voulu lui car jugé trop radical
ça va
rencontrer les jeunes d'écolines je me
suis demandé s'il y avait une jeunesse
aussi radicale qui s'opposait à eux en
fouillant un petit peu sur les réseaux
sociaux j'ai découvert une page tenue
par des jeunes israéliens
anti-colonisation ils sont proches de
l'extrême gauche et ils sont aujourd'hui
ultra minoritaires dans le pays
qui aide des bergers palestiniens en
fait à pouvoir traverser pour rejoindre
leur terre parce qu'en fait il y a des
colons israéliens qui qui parfois les
empêche de passer ou l'armée
[Musique]
ils défendent l'idée que les
Palestiniens devraient avoir les mêmes
droits que les Israéliens et ce genre de
position leur vaut des déferlements de
haine de la part d'autres juifs
israéliens
une autre partie du groupe qui était
avec des bergers et qui a été pris à
partir par des colons
voir si tout va bien alors à ce moment
là on a dû faire un énorme détour pour
les rejoindre du coup je vais arriver
quelques minutes trop tard les
activistes sont filmés avec leur propre
caméra donc les images que vous allez
voir viennent de
[Applaudissements]
alors je vais essayer de vous décrypter
un petit peu cette vidéo ici c'est un
colon juif israélien il utilise son
enfant comme bouclier humain
ce que l'on comme les cinq autres hommes
qui sont arrivés avec lui vivent-ils
également dans un avant-poste à quelques
centaines de mètres d'ici ils essaient
de faire fuir le troupeau de moutons du
berger qui lui est palestinien pour pas
qu'il ne s'approche de leur zone
et ici c'est une des activités
anti-colonisation qui elle aussi est
juive israélienne mais qui essayent avec
son groupe de protéger le berger
palestinien
c'est tous ici à part le berger sont des
Juifs israéliens et ils se détestent
[Applaudissements]
ce que vous venez de voir c'est une
scène quasi quotidienne ici pour mieux
comprendre il faut regarder une carte
quelques secondes là on a l'état
d'Israël ici c'est la 6 Jordanie et à
travers les années les colonies
israéliennes se sont de plus en plus
étendues sur les zones palestiniennes au
mépris de toutes les condamnations de la
communauté internationale pour vous
donner une idée en 2022 Israël a été
condamnée par l'ONU plus que tous les
autres pays du monde réunis au total
depuis 2015 il y a eu 140 résolutions
qui ont condamné Israël dont la plupart
pour avoir colonisé illégalement des
territoires palestiniens
bon on retourne sur le terrain je suis
finalement arrivé sur place quand
l'armée venait de s'interposer entre les
colons les activistes et le berger
dans ce format sur la jeunesse
israélienne je vous ai présenté les
colons israéliens radicaux la minorité
d'extrême gauche mais je vous ai pas
encore parlé de la jeunesse beaucoup
moins politisée cette fameuse majorité
silencieuse
[Musique]
j'ai pas de nouvelles je voulais savoir
si le mec qui nous avait répondu il faut
savoir si ça se passait bien parce que
ça se trouve
[Musique]
34 ans je suis arrivé en Israël et à
environ 9 ans et voilà je suis dj
passionné depuis l'âge de 16 ans à peu
près et aujourd'hui voilà je mixe de la
transe
alors en fait Michael il a grandi en
France ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
chaque année près de 70 000 nouveaux
immigrants des juifs venus du monde
entier viennent s'installer en Israël
c'est ce qu'on appelle faire la Lyre
de venir en Israël
moi même si j'avais 25 ans j'ai pas
choisi tant que ça je suis mes parents
mes parents faisaient la LIA je les ai
suivis je me suis dit pourquoi pas et au
pire si ça marche pas je me donne un an
et bah de fil en aiguille bah c'est un
peu tracé ma voix
est-ce que vous parlez entre vous
justement du conflit un peu les
Palestiniens
entre nous on parle jamais du conflit on
parle des attentats bien sûr quand
l'actualité est chaude au jour le jour
ça tient deux jours mais c'est tout on
parle jamais jamais du conflit
palestinien
parce que
nous touchent beaucoup plus
chacun son quotidien
je passe une semaine difficile
la meuf m'a quitté t'as vu le match du
PSG mais si ah champion du monde c'est
ça qui nous qui nous intéresse comme
partout comme tout le monde que je vais
mettre là ah non j'ai trouvé
moi je t'aurais conseillé on sait jamais
ta voiture à l'envers prêt à partir
on va voir un peu ce qui se passe
il y a déjà une vingtaine de voitures
c'est cool
[Musique]
alors là en fait on est super tôt le
matin en plein milieu de la saison
d'Annie
on fait la fête toute la nuit j'ai
l'impression qu'ils sont pas prêtes
s'arrêter
[Musique]
non
un nouvel immigrants
et non non j'ai habité dans un pays
parce que l'opportunité de venir comme à
l'époque avec les États-Unis l'Amérique
du Sud un des pays qui accueillent je me
suis dit pourquoi pas en couple par
exemple avec une Palestinienne
[Musique]
je pense que je suis suffisamment de
choix chez les Juifs faut que je puisse
trouver ce que je la trouvais
je ne cherche pas non plus et puis c'est
pas
je sais pas trop comment ça pour arriver
parce que je fréquente pas du tout ce
ces gens-là une fréquente pas non plus
c'est qu'en fait il y a vraiment deux
jeunesses qui vivent côte à côte
bah parce qu'on est pas si côte à côte
que ça c'est un village à côté
c'est des fois une ligne de front c'est
l'éducation c'est une langue
et c'est peut-être des
philosophie différentes aussi
[Musique]
voilà c'est la fin de ce reportage
j'espère que vous l'avez aimé ce que
vous avez appris des choses c'est le cas
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner à le
partager à commenter et je vous dis à
très bientôt pour une prochaine vidéo